NADA، شكرًا لوجودك هنا، لقد كان أمان
واحدًا من
المشاهد العديدة للاحتجاج المناهض لإسرائيل والغرب،
ويخطر ببالي أننا لم يبق لدينا سوى
أسبوعين على هجوم حماس
على إسرائيل الذي كانت إسرائيل هي الموضوع فيه.
يبدو أن هذه القسوة لم تكسبها أي
تعاطف مع أي من هؤلاء
المتظاهرين المؤيدين للفلسطينيين.
لماذا ننظر جيدًا؟ أعتقد أن هذه
طريقة غير عادلة لوصف ما
نراه يحدث في الأردن وفي معظم أنحاء
الشرق الأوسط عندما نتحدث إلى
المتظاهرين في يومنا هذا.  على أرض الواقع،
تخبرنا الغالبية العظمى منهم أن الأمر لا
يتعلق بحماس، ولا يتعلق الأمر بالتعبير عن
أي لامبالاة تجاه الهجمات ضد
المدنيين الإسرائيليين في 7 أكتوبر/تشرين الأول، بل في الواقع
بالنسبة للغالبية العظمى من الأشخاص الذين
تحدثنا إليهم هنا في الأردن
في الواقع، الأشخاص الذين
تحدثنا إليهم في جميع أنحاء المنطقة، يتعلق هذا
بالصراع، وهي قضية
بدأت قبل وقت طويل من السابع من أكتوبر، هؤلاء هم
متظاهرون مؤيدون للفلسطينيين
يتظاهرون ضد الضربات الجوية الإسرائيلية
على قطاع غزة والتي، كما
نعلم، كان لها تأثير كبير.
خسائر إنسانية مدمرة، خسائر بشرية
مدمرة، عدد القتلى في ارتفاع كما ذكرت كلاريسا يومًا
بعد ساعة وبالطبع بالنسبة للكثيرين
هنا، هذه دعوة لإنهاء
الحصار على غزة، إنهاء الحصار كما
قلت للكثيرين، لقد بدأ هذا  قبل وقت طويل من
السابع من تشرين الأول (أكتوبر)، كان الأمر يتعلق بما هو أكثر من مجرد
ما نراه يحدث الآن في غزة،
إنه يتعلق بالعنف الذي
نشهده في الضفة الغربية، إنه يتعلق
بتوسيع المستوطنات التي
يعتبرها الكثيرون في
المجتمع الدولي بمثابة  أن تكون قانونية بموجب
القانون الدولي، فهذه أزمة
وقضية محورية بالنسبة للكثيرين
هنا في الأردن، حيث كان أكثر من نصف
السكان إما فلسطينيين أو
من أصل فلسطيني، وهذا محسوس
وينعكس في جميع أنحاء الشرق الأوسط،
انظر الآن يا ملك.  عبد الله
الأردني، إنهم يدينون العنف
الذي نشهده وأعتقد أن ما
قاله اليوم في مؤتمر السلام
يجسد ويجسد
ما يشعر به الكثير من الناس في شوارع
عمان وفي جميع أنحاء الشرق الأوسط،
اسمح لي فقط  اقرأ لكم قليلا
مما قاله، حيث قال إن
حملة القصف المتواصلة الجارية في
غزة بينما نتحدث هي قاسية
وغير معقولة على كل المستويات، إنها
عقاب جماعي للمحاصرين
ومساعدة الناس، إنها انتهاك صارخ
للقانون الإنساني الدولي، إنها كذلك.  إن
أي جريمة حرب في أي مكان آخر، فإن مهاجمة
البنية التحتية المدنية
وتجويع جميع السكان عمدًا من الغذاء
والماء والكهرباء والضروريات الأساسية
سيكون أمرًا
مدانًا، هذه هي رسالة العاهل
الأردني الملك عبد الله، هذه هي الرسالة
التي سمعناها في جميع أنحاء الشرق
الأوسط، هذا هو التجمع  الصرخة
التي سمعناها من
المتظاهرين هنا في أمان، وكما
تعلمون جيدًا، هذه هي الرسالة التي
سمعناها من مجموعات حقوق الإنسان الدولية
ومجموعات المساعدة NOS الموجودة على الأرض
والتي تحاول التخفيف مما
ذكرته كلاريسا للتو من
كارثة إنسانية تتكشف  في قطاع غزة